mr. Dafoe if I might start with you my
understanding is that you saw Robert
Eggers his previous film the witch and
you reached out and you chatted for a
bit what was that conversation about oh
just to express my admiration for the
witch and just to check him out
really I saw the witch and I saw it in
the perfect situation I knew nothing
about it
I had been away working and I saw a
movie I saw the poster I went in to see
a movie and I thought wow there's a
filmmaker here who is he and I wanted to
meet him so I arranged to have a meeting
we met we had a lot in common we both
come from the theatre yeah just really
hit it off and I just said listen if you
have anything you know what I'd love to
work with you because I think what
you're doing is wonderful it's very
specific there's great rigor he's
playing with the film language that is
very cinematic he's working in film you
know a complete world a period a period
piece that doesn't always point that
it's a period pace you can really enter
it so all those things really you said
keep me in mind for future projects and
then along comes this story which was
inspired in part by a real event what do
we know about what actually happened and
how did that inspire you our my brother
was working on a on a on a ghost story
in a lighthouse and when he said ghost
story in a lighthouse I thought damn
that's a great idea I wish I'd had it
hopefully he will fail miserably at
writing it and I can steal the idea with
his permission and that sort of that's
going too far but I asked him a couple
months after how was your lighthouse
movie coming and he said you know it's
not great and I so I asked him if I
could take a crack at it and because we
need said ghost story in a lighthouse I
pictured a black and white crusty dusty
rusty musty atmosphere with you know
very much the visual imagery of the
dinner scene in this movie and I wanted
to find a story that could match that
atmosphere and so I began researching
and very quickly I came across what's
generally called the smalls light house
tragedy that took place in Wales around
1800 and the ending is somewhat folktale
like so I one doesn't know how true the
story is but supposedly it's true and to
lighthouse keepers both named Thomas one
older one younger a big storm comes
they're marooned on their lighthouse
station the old one dies the young one
goes crazy that's the the very basic
bones of this movie and because they
were both named Thomas I thought this
this could be an interesting two hander
about identity it's about many other
things but but that's how it how it
began and then I thought okay we should
probably have a mermaid we need to have
a mystery in in the light and and and
Afrin a lens that that beautiful art
deco spaceship you know was going to
place us in the second half of the 19th
century with this story and because I
wanted the foghorn with that certain
sound and I wanted the lighthouse
station to be a certain level of
dilapidated that was going to place us
probably in the 1890s so basically after
many years of doing other things I
called my brother up and said you know
that lighthouse movie let's let's let's
do it together and so in the past couple
years leading up to this and that's what
we did and Jaron talked about shooting
this film cuz you and Rob together made
some very specific choices that led to
some very powerful effects and I
understand it involved some crazy lenses
to make the two very handsome gentlemen
in between us look not so great well I
think I remember it like for the witch I
asked Rob like how much does vanity
matter when I go and shoot this thing
he's like not at all you know and kind
of I can see that pattern going forward
and by forgiveness but like it worked
really hard to make them look as you
know bad as possible
and a lot of the inspiration was just
like early photography and you know
people think of black and white but
there are a lot of ways to do it like
you know how you what colors you extract
to make your black/white image a lot
really you know early photography it's
just it's really there's no red light
it's like sensitive blue and UV and you
know you know how everyone looks under a
black light you know so I was trying to
find a filter that could just eliminate
all the red light and you know as much
of the green before we're just like
cutting too much light to make it
impractical to shoot but yeah anyway
ultimately a Schneider made a custom
filter that you know emulated what's
called worth of chromatic film like just
you know C's blue and and some green and
that's it so anything that's red like
you know skin tone you know it darkens
that immensely and the skies are bright
and you know starts to look like a early
film but it's wasn't like checking boxes
to make it look like you know what's
what's old-timey let's do that I think
it it was just more of a general delving
of the past it's just like a feeling you
know hopefully it's not obvious
hopefully it's just you just see a
texture and and it just takes you there
without you really you know I think
self-conscious about it to get all of
those shots required a fair amount of
rehearsal and I have heard Willam
describe his take on how he thinks you
feel about rehearsal I would love to
hear Robert Pattinson your thoughts on
how Willem Dafoe approaches rehearsal
and how that differs from yours if I
might with an enormous amount of
enthusiasm he's kind of like a human
dynamo I mean right from the very first
day he just was really really relishing
it and and I think his I interpreted his
relish for rehearsal as being total
comfort with the script and exactly
knowing exactly what he would want to go
with the part which terrified me
because I didn't know what I was going
to do at all and
period but then I realized after that
I'm the second time we ran through the
entire movie and rehearsal Willem did it
in entirely different ways
[Laughter]
the only leg I had to stand on and
terrified me even more had but it was it
was fun even though even even though it
was sort of vaguely traumatizing
experience like it was actually really
fun I think doing anything with the
balloon was pretty fun let's talk about
the vaguely traumatizing and and I'd
love to hear from both of you but what
were the hardest moments to make in this
film because we shouldn't you know
actually filming in Nova Scotia
it was quote-unquote spring but still
rather chilly a lot of this was real
well and what was the most excruciating
moment for you you just saw the movie
the being buried alive wasn't too too
cool
don't want to do that again any time
soon I don't want to do it period any
time soon but yeah that was that was
challenging but like everything you know
I'm an actor I want those things I want
to live in that world I
so the horrible weather is part of it it
tells you what to do it informs what
you're doing so I can't complain about
it this was out this was real did I
complain did I cry but Jaron is fond
ofor a lobster right here but come on
you gotta cut me a slack man we were
like a slave to that camera a film like
the film language is so beautiful in
this that in fact the rehearsals the
rehearsals normally the rehearsals are
for you know to figure out the scenes to
get the actors comfortable this
rehearsal was to see where the camera
was so we could fit into the frame to
find out how to block things that were
best for the photography but you know
what that was a beautiful discipline and
it was a beautiful structure it it took
away
that's for bat lack a better word let's
say choices or things that we had to
think about and it became a discipline
and really helped to bring us into that
world so much quicker and gave us a kind
of clear-eyed clearer idea of what
Robert and jaian were trying to do so
that rehearsal was unusual because it
was really for camera it wasn't so much
for the actors a thank you so much to
all of you for taking the time